time to talk about the race for clark
county district attorney and the
challenger joining us right now ozzy
fumo joining us gazi good to see you sir
good to see you thank you for having me
john you have a long history obviously
in public service you're now in in in
the private sector as well but uh first
and foremost why do you want to uh be
d.a you're not a great question you know
i
thought about it long and hard earlier
in the year and and it was it was really
the district attorney's support staff
within the office who contacted me and
one thing i want to say is the district
attorney's office has great attorneys in
that office uh great support staff they
just have lousy leadership
and it was it was their
encouragement that really
helped me want to enter this race what
is in as you say lousy what is uh so
lousy about uh mr wolfson you know and
his performance you know one of the
things when he when he got the job he
said i want to lead by example
and and you know we had district
attorneys david roger would pick up a
file come into court fight a case stuart
bell before him pick up a file
come into court fight a case we haven't
seen that from the leadership there in
10 years the other thing that is really
discouraging i think within the office
and things that i heard within the
office was you know when he first took
over he had a person in his office i
think her name was audrey who stole
money from not only his campaign but
from the district attorney's office and
he chose not to prosecute her now these
these were attorneys who were doing bake
sales for officers who were killed in
the cc's pizza shooting two officers
died and
the district attorney's office raised
money
for this event to help the victims
families and she stole that money and
when wolfson decided not to prosecute
his his staff
that lowered the integrity of the entire
office and it's been downhill from there
and that's not just coming from me
that's coming from people within the
office they felt it i'm going to ask you
more about sort of the the some of the
accusations of favoritism in a moment
here but um
if you're elected what changes would you
make straight away
straight away i think you know that the
leadership in that office has to change
like i said great attorneys lousy
leadership and it starts from the top it
starts from you picking up a file i
don't think he's been in the courtroom
or done at trial since he's been a
district attorney i know that for a fact
hasn't done a trial probably in 10 or 15
years before that as a defense attorney
which is unheard of so just that lack of
leadership there change that structure
put new people in i want a district
attorney's office that looks like the
community you've got two white males
leading the criminal division you have a
civil division that hasn't changed in
years we need to shake things up a
little bit change that organizational
structure put district attorneys in
there who have the experience but that
look like the community that they serve
so
i get the impression here that you
you would want to make a pretty
significant shake-up at the da's office
why do you think it's necessary aside
from uh your feelings on mr wolfson in
terms of the the nuts and bolts of
prosecution why does such a shake-up
needed among the rank and file well
because the morale is at an all-time low
right people are leaving that office in
droves not just attorneys support staff
investigators secretaries paralegals
they don't feel like they're a team they
don't feel like they get the support
from the top down and when i get in
there that's the first thing i want to
do let them know that i will lead by
example i will be in the courtroom with
them when i can when the big cases are
there i will be there with them i will
be leading the fight i'm not going to
hang them out to dry i'm not going to
take files away from them say we're
going to dismiss this case or we're not
going to prosecute that one we're going
to punish the deserving and we're going
to treat everybody the same you know
john our laws are based on we the people
not we the privileged
you're you're again touching on the this
idea and i think there's almost an
insinuation of favoritism uh in the
current da's office and specifically
with mr wolfson with uh maybe high
profile cases or cases involving you
were talking about with with previous in
situations
do you believe
that the district attorney is uh
playing favorites with certain
defendants in certain cases because of
connections that he has in the district
in the in the city absolutely give me an
example uh henry nichols let's talk
about henry nichols all right that that
kit man came here from california with
enough drugs to kill an army right
paraded through one of our casinos with
enough dangerous drugs to kill everybody
in that casino went out and partied all
day
was caught in his hotel room with
another woman
with those drugs and if you and i had
been caught in that hotel room with that
quantity of drugs under those facts you
and i would be doing 10 to life in
prison henry nichols in fargo got a
dismissal
500 000 donation to a non-profit charity
of their choice which we still don't
know what it is yet that still hasn't
been made public and that case gets
dismissed that's we can't justify that
it's a pretty strong accusation i know
we kind of addressed this with mr
wolfson when he was here several weeks
ago and she strongly denies claims of
favoritism he says you know his he and
his office
play it by the book there is no
favoritism and if you look at their
record uh they he stands behind it
certainly
how how how sure are you that uh there
are some issues within the department
that need to be addressed with that with
that issue well i've heard it from
people within the department i've heard
it but that's that's sort of
taken care of isn't it it's taken their
files it's people who are in the
trenches with them who feel like they're
disrespected because they have a case
that they can prosecute that they know
they can go forward and it's taken off
their desk because of a favor to another
attorney or an individual who donated to
a campaign and it's just not right we
need to treat everybody equal right
equal justice under the law is what we
have everybody should be treated fairly
if if we're going to give that guy that
kind of bonus for those kind of facts
then we need to give everybody that kind
of bonus for those kind of facts so
let's maybe brush on
the current high profile case happening
right now recently with the las vegas
raider henry ruggs now off the team now
accused of death resulting
dui resulting in death
that's a high profile case there's high
profile attorneys involved
how as district attorney would you
handle that case any differently from
any other similar kind of case well the
first thing i would do is you have a
team of district attorneys who handled
the uis right they take care of those
cases that's their wheelhouse that's
their expertise that's their specialty
and you let them handle the case just
like it was anybody else you don't say
this is henry ruggs from the raider so
he gets a pass somebody died here so you
just treat him as defendant x the same
way you would treat any other defendant
who was in the same or similar
circumstances right you don't give
anybody favoritism just because they're
high profile just because they have a
lot of money or because they're their
attorneys are now if if the you apply
the law to the facts and the person
deserves to go to prison or be found
guilty that should happen you can't just
say we're going to give this guy a pass
and that's the feeling in the office
right now they don't have that he's
behind us he's going to let us do our
work
just to be clear again you're suggesting
that there is some level of this this
favoritism absolutely and it wouldn't
exist in your district attorney's office
okay
um one of the uh
items that mr wolfson touts is some of
the diversion programs they have within
the da's office
how would you either continue that
enhance it to maybe restrict it or draw
it down if you're elected you know what
that's one of the things we need to do
is do more in restorative justice right
we can't be having death by
incarceration the war on drugs didn't
work when i first started practicing 25
27 years ago now you know if you got
into drug court you know you're a
first-time nonviolent offender with a
drug case you completed this three-year
program you went to counseling you were
tested you got a job you did everything
you were supposed to do and your case
was dismissed under the current
administration it's a condition of
probation you still have that felony on
your record you you can't get a job you
can't work and it's twisted around to
something it was never intended to be
the other thing we have is is veterans
court things like that veterans
sometimes they need to get into these
programs
because they committed a violent act
right they have ptsd they do something
the district attorney's office right now
under the current leadership prevents
those that need it the most from getting
into those programs so you're getting
people in the veterans court who are you
know misuse of a park bench or
jaywalking those aren't necessarily they
deserve to get some benefit too they
served our country but it's the more
violent crimes that the district
attorney's office under the current
administration is blocking that need
those programs that aren't getting it so
what i would do is open it up right and
if the district attorney feels that they
shouldn't a defendant should not be in
that program what i would submit we'd
have to make this a legislative change
is you argue it to the judge that's why
we elect these judges right they make
the decision right now the district
attorney's office is the gatekeeper and
i would lessen that i would i would open
those gates so that more people could
get into the programs they need because
we're wasting money incarcerating people
costs us is taxpayers 155 dollars a day
to keep somebody in custody fifty four
thousand dollars a year hundreds of
millions of dollars by clark county
taxpayers every year to warehouse people
that don't necessarily need to be there
if we could get him into these programs
and the current administration is
blocking
i i believe both of you are
against the death penalty although mr
wolfson certainly wants to keep it on
the books as the the potential sort of
the threat of a penalty for for a
defendant uh if your district attorney
what would you do with the death penalty
you know when i was a legislator both
sessions i was up there i introduced
bills or supported bills to end the
death penalty state sanctioned murder
just doesn't work it does it's not a
deterrent i don't know any client i've
represented people are charged with
capital cases for years not one of them
says well i thought about i could get
the death penalty if i do this i decided
to do it anyway it's not a deterrent it
doesn't work we spend millions of
dollars every year doing it and i i
would i would be hard-pressed to see any
case that i think would be worthy of
that the current district attorney came
up to the legislature supporting it
right he's not he's not opposed to it he
supports the death penalty i'm against
and my record shows that from my
legislative history
this is more of a law enfo well
prosecutor's office is law enforcement
but
there's been an increase in crime
violent crimes across
clark county
what measures as a prosecutor would you
take her in the prosecutor's office
could you take
to
do something on the penalty phase and on
the prosecution phase to try and
[Music]
deter
this kind of activity in the community
right so what we need to do is you need
to protect the communities our biggest
job is protect everybody from violent
crimes but we need to think long term on
some of this stuff right you can't just
put everybody in prison and warehouse
them first time non-violent offenders
drug addicted people you know they
deserve to get into counseling programs
we need to teach treat drug addiction as
an illness and not a crime the clark
county detention center and the prisons
are ill-equipped to handle mental
illness and drug addiction we need to
get those people into the programs that
will help them and if we can take them
out of the prison system like i said not
spending that fifty four thousand
dollars a year on that and spending say
a ten thousand dollar program on the
outside getting them healthy they won't
come back into the system so does what
you're discussing and some of the things
you measures you've discussed before
does that require more funding for the
prosecutor's office or just reshuffling
where the money goes it's reshuffling
where the money goes eventually we're
going to save this county so much money
that we're going to be able to put money
back into the system we do need to hire
more prosecutors they're leaving like
crazy support staff is leaving like
crazy there is a need for to hire more
prosecutors to do the
crimes but you need to punish the
deserving we need to focus on murders
home invasion sex assault and not these
non-violent first-time offenders we need
to get them into programs
final question is this kind of goes back
a little bit to the the high profile
cases and the favoritism that you're
accusing your opponent of uh sort of
engaging in
you're a defense attorney right now how
do you disentangle yourself from cases
from
cases at your firm
if you're elected to the prosecutor's
office what do you do to make sure that
those threads don't linger on when
you're in public service again so what
you need to treat everybody the same
right no matter who the defendant is no
matter who the attorney is you just have
to follow the law it's a very simple
formula right i spent my entire career
defending the crop
defending the constitution
and the other side i will be there
protecting the citizens of nevada but
you have to treat every single person
the same you can't say this person has
more money than that person this person
has lighter skin than that person
therefore they get a pass that's not the
way it's going to work under my
administration everybody will treat it
be treated equally under the law it's we
the people not we the privilege but i
mean if i'm a voter at home how can i be
sure that again because of your business
and your profession right now when
you're in the prosecutor's office there
aren't still going to be some
entanglements with your partners in your
your current uh law firm no i would
disassociate that from it in fact those
cases would probably be conflict off
anybody that i've represented in the
past accused would be
would be conflicted off right they would
go to the attorney general's office but
uh every every not every but we've had
district attorneys who are former
criminal defense attorneys and it's just
the way the system works they were they
would conflict off those certain amount
of cases and they would proceed
accordingly but everybody in in clark
county will be treated the same under
the law when i'm elected district
attorney we're not going to have this
favoritism anymore the district
attorney's office is no longer for sale
in clark county all right well it's
going to be a very interesting race ozzy
fumo thank you for joining us we'll
continue to watch the race for clark
county district attorney thank you sir